[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend bei
seinem Versuch die Ukraine zu erobern
greift Russland jetzt zu einer
altbekannten Methode in besetzten
Gebieten sogenannte Volksbefragungen
abzuhalten die bei ein Beitritt zu
Russland entscheiden sollen das hat mit
demokratischen Prozessen die einen
tatsächlichen Volkswillen abbilden
natürlich nichts zu tun sondern ist Teil
der russischen Kriegsstrategie klar ist
auch dass solche Referenten in von
truppenbesetzten Kriegsgebieten
international nicht anerkannt werden
Putin selbst dürfte auch kaum erwarten
dass er damit irgendeinen
völkerrechtlichen Anspruch erwirbt was
steckt also dahinter
dass du gleich ein Gespräch doch zuvor
gibt Dalia Antar einen Überblick über
die aktuelle Entwicklung
heute in Donezk das Kamerateam wird von
der Separatisten Führung begleitet die
Meldung über das geplante Referendum wie
sie es hier nennen ist gerade ein paar
Stunden alt
zur Frage wir werden eine Einheit sein
es wird sich normal anfühlen wir sind
nicht nur anerkannt sondern werden
offiziell Teil Russland sein zurück zu
Hause
hier unterstützen das wir alle deshalb
denke ich alles wird gut diese lange
Reise wird nicht umsonst gewesen sein
wir schaffen das der Sieg ist unser
neben der Region Don jetzt sollen auch
in den Regionen luhansk in rerson und in
Teilen saporicias scheinreferenten
abgehalten werden geplant vom 23 bis 27
September
Beginn der Spezial Militäroperation und
auch davor haben wir gesagt dass die
Leute in den betroffenen Gebieten selbst
über ihr Schicksal entscheiden sollen
und die aktuelle Situation bestätigt uns
dass sie ihr Schicksal selbst in die
Hand nehmen wollen
mit Hilfe von scheinreferenten ohne
Zustimmung der Ukraine unter Kriegsrecht
und nicht nach der demokratischen
Prinzipien so sehen Sie es nicht nur
hier in Kiew
sie können denken was sie wollen
ukrainisches Territorium gehört
niemandem sonst sie können entscheiden
was immer Sie wollen
dieser Schritt zeigt mir dass ihnen
nichts anderes übrig bleibt sie merken
dass die Gegenoffensive unausweichlich
ist und wollen diese Gebiete zu ihrem
eigenen erklären
aus New York die Reaktion von ukraines
Außenminister Kollegah dann auch kurz
und knapp
die Russen können machen was sie wollen
das ändert gar nichts
auch Künstler Scholz reagierte am Rande
der UN-Generalversammlung
unmissverständlich die Ukraine hat jedes
Recht die Integrität und Souveränität
des eigenen Landes und die eigene
Demokratie zu verteidigen dabei
unterstützen wir die Ukraine und deshalb
ist auch ganz ganz klar dass diese
Schein Referenden
nicht akzeptiert werden können dass sie
nicht gedeckt sind vom tölkerrecht und
von den Verständigungen die die
Weltgemeinschaft gefunden hat von einer
weiteren Eskalation sprach
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
scheinreferenten haben keine Legitimität
und ändern nichts an der Natur von
Russlands Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine dies ist eine weitere Eskalation
in putinskrieg die internationale
Gemeinschaft muss diese eklatante
Verletzung des Völkerrechts verurteilen
und die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
verstärken
die scheinreferenten gelten als Reaktion
auf die aktuelle ukrainische
Gegenoffensive im Osten des Landes
Russland fielen seit Wochen offenbar die
Soldaten an der Front im Eilverfahren
verschärfte das russische Parlament
heute gleich mehrere Strafgesetze unter
anderem drohen befehlsverweigerern lange
Haftstrafen das Russland eine
Mobilmachung vorbereiten oder gar den
Kriegszustand verhängen könnte darin
sehen Kreml Beobachter heute hier
zumindest einen Hinweis
darauf wollen wir mit einer
ausgewiesenen
russland-expertin sprechen mit Sabine
Fischer von der Stiftung Wissenschaft
und Politik in Berlin
Forschungsschwerpunkt russische
Sicherheitspolitik guten Abend Frau
Fischer
hallo Frau Slomka diese Referenten mit
denen wird putin wird Russland keinerlei
internationale Anerkennung finden warum
macht er das dann jetzt trotzdem und
warum jetzt
die Referenten bedeutet das bedeuten
dass Russland und dass der russische
Präsident Putin den Konflikt weiter
eskalieren das ist eine Reaktion auf die
Erfolge der ukrainischen Gegenoffensive
in den letzten zwei Wochen und es geht
hier darum vor allen Dingen darum die
Gebiete zu annektieren also Russland
einzuferleiben und damit dann jeden
Angriff den die Ukraine in Zukunft macht
zu einem Angriff direkt auf russisches
Staatsterritorium zu erklären also es
geht hier um abschreckungen und das
ganze ist natürlich auch ein starkes
Signal an westliche Regierungen sowohl
im Hinblick auf Waffenlieferungen als
auch in der Hoffnung des westliche
Akteure
EU-Staaten zum Beispiel dann die Ukraine
darauf dazu drängen könnten in Vorhand
Verhandlungen einzutreten und eben auch
Konzessionen zu machen Russland
gegenüber um den Konflikt zu der
eskalieren naja aber so ein Referendum
dass das wäre eine Farce also wenn das
auch niemand dann anerkennt wird ja auch
niemand sagen oh ja das ist jetzt
russisches Staatsterritorium da dürfen
jetzt die Kinder nicht mehr hinschießen
das ist richtig das ist eine Phase es
handelt sich tatsächlich um
scheinreferenten genauso wie die frühe
durchgeführten Referenten sogenannten
Referenten auf der Krim auch in anderen
Konfliktgebieten in der russischen
Nachbarschaft
scheinreferenten waren also es handelt
sich hier nicht um wirkliche
Volksbefragungen und ich denke das Putin
gerade dabei ist einen weiteren
schwerwiegenden Fehler zu machen was die
Einschätzung der Situation anbelangt
denn ich gehe nicht davon aus dass diese
Schritte die ukrainische Gegenoffensive
stoppen werden und ich gehe auch nicht
davon aus dass westliche Regierungen
ihre Unterstützung für die Ukraine
aufgeben jetzt es könnte aber vielleicht
in Russland selbstwirkung erzielen also
man wenn man es ein bisschen in diesen
telegram Kanälen oder so unterwegs ist
dann fällt ja doch auf dass die
schärfste Kritik an Putin nicht von
Kriegsgegnern kommt sondern eigentlich
von nationalistischen kriegsbefürwortern
die ihn drängen wollen dann noch mehr
reinzugehen
ja absolut und ich denke dieser Schritt
ist auch eine Reaktion auf die
Instabilität die wiederum der Erfolg der
ukrainischen Gegenoffensive in Russland
verursacht hat also man hat sehr
deutlich gesehen dass Kritik aufgekommen
ist an Putin sehr stark eben auch von
nationalistischer Seite und zum Beispiel
ja auch mobil machen gefordert worden
ist von russischen Nationalisten auch
von ramsanker dürow dem Herrscher
Tschetscheniens also hier ist Druck
entstanden durch diese ukrainischen
militärischen Erfolge auf die wird jetzt
reagiert und damit haben sich die
ultra-nationalistischen Kräfte wieder
einmal wie auch im Februar letztendlich
durchgesetzt es gibt kaum mehr moderate
Stimmen in diesem russischen politischen
System die in solchen Situationen auf
Mäßigung drängen könnten was ich jetzt
diese
referendungsgeschichte noch mal ganz
praktisch angerufen das ist Kriegsgebiet
in luhans-
nicht komplett idiotisch aussieht wenn
nur zehn Leute sich beteiligen also wer
ist jetzt eigentlich noch in diesem
Gebieten und wir sind diese sogenannten
Separatisten ist ja auch so ein
russisches framing Separatisten die das
durchführen
die Akteure die in den besetzten
Gebieten an der Macht sind sind keine
reparatisten Separatisten sondern das
sind letztendlich von Russland
gesteuerter Akteure die in diesen
Gebieten eine Gewaltherrschaft errichtet
haben und
letztendlich müssen diese Akteure keine
irgendwie internationalen Kriterien
entsprechenden Referenten durchführen
also es sind jetzt schon es wird jetzt
schon organisiert es werden
sogenannte referendumspunkte
eingerichtet es gibt Gerüchte die
wahrscheinlich oder die die sicherlich
ein Stück Wahrheit beinhalten das
Brigaden geformt werden sollen die von
Wohnung zu Wohnungen gehen um Menschen
ja letztendlich unter Druck zu setzen
damit sie an diesen Referenten
teilnehmen also man wird irgendwie ein
Ergebnis herbeiführen dieses Ergebnis
wird hochgradig manipuliert sein und den
Rest wird die russische Propaganda
erledigen
heute gab es außerdem in der Duma eine
schärfere Beschluss für schärfere
Gesetze im Kriegsfall oder im Fall einer
mobilenmachung wie sich die russische
Soldaten zu verhalten haben oder bei
fahnenfluchtmoltereien und ähnlichen was
ihn dann für drakonische Strafen drohen
wie interpretieren sie das worauf deutet
das für sie hin
das deutet für mich darauf hin dass der
russische Präsident tatsächlich
zumindest auf eine Teilmobilmachung
zusteuert und es zeigt auch noch einmal
dass dieses politische Regime sich gegen
die eigene Bevölkerung eben tatsächlich
nur noch über harte Repressionen
durchsetzen kann denn die Tatsache dass
dieses Gesetz das heute für aber diese
Gesetze die heute verabschiedet worden
sind überhaupt nötig waren zeigt eben
dass es keinen
Enthusiasmus gibt für diesen Krieg und
dass sich viele Männer in Russland nach
wie vor und auch diese der Mobilmachung
und der Werbung der russischen
Streitkräfte systematisch entziehen und
deswegen wird jetzt eben zu drakonischen
strafanrohrungen gegriffen um
aus russischer Person aus prospektive
des russischen Regimes hier Disziplin
herzustellen
danke für das Gespräch und ihre
Einschätzung und Expertise
vielen dank ihnen
das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen aufgezeichnet und die für heute
Abend angekündigte große Rede von Putin
die hat bislang übrigens nicht
stattgefunden die Aussage dass das
inakzeptable scheinreferenten sein
machte Olaf Scholz am Rande der
UNO-Vollversammlung in New York er wird
dort in den nächsten Stunden seine erste
Rede als deutscher Bundeskanzler halten
der Angriff auf die Ukraine und die
weltweiten Folgen dieses Krieges sind
zentrales Thema der Vollversammlung auch
Präsident selensky wird zugeschaltet
werden ausnahmsweise darf er das per
Video der Versuch Russlands das sind
Vorfeld zu verhindern war gescheitert
nur eine Handvoll Länder wie Syrien oder
Kuba unterstützten Moskau dabei selbst
China und Indien enthielten sich
eine Woche lang ist New York nun also
wieder einmal die große Bühne der
Weltpolitik vom Auftakt berichtet
Johannes Hano
[Musik]
New York heute morgen so voll weiß hier
im Hauptsitz der Vereinten Nationen
schon lange nicht mehr zum ersten Mal
seit Beginn der Pandemie sind sie
wiedergekommen die Staats- und
Regierungschefs und Chefinnen aus der
ganzen Welt begrüßt vom Generalsekretär
persönlich viel steht für die
Weltorganisation auf dem Spiel in diesen
Zeiten auch der Bundeskanzler ist
gekommen in seiner Eröffnungsrede warnt
der UN-Generalsekretär dann das ist um
die Zukunft der Vereinten Nationen gehe
machen wir uns keine Illusionen wir sind
in schwerer See ein Winter der
Unzufriedenheit sieht am Horizont auf
die Lebenshaltungskosten galoppieren
Vertrauen schwindet Ungleichheiten
explodieren
die Vereinten Nationen und die ideale
ihrer Kater sind in Gefahr
die Welt und die Vereinten Nationen am
Abgrund der russische Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine Wirtschaftskrise Hunger
Inflation mit seinem Besuch in New York
will der Bundeskanzler deutlich machen
wie ernst auch die Bundesregierung die
Lage nimmt 15 Jahre ist es her dass mit
Angela Merkel ein deutscher
Regierungschef auf der
Generalversammlung gesprochen hat
Bundeskanzler Scholz machte vor seiner
Rede am Abend klar wie aus seiner Sicht
die Hauptverantwortung für die Krise der
Weltgemeinschaft trägt
der russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine hat die Sicherheit zum
Friedensordnung nicht nur Europas
sondern der ganzen Welt gefährdet die
Verständigung dass man nicht mehr mit
Gewalt
versucht sich das Territorium seines
Nachbarns anzueignen ist zerbrochen
durch den imperialistischen Krieg den
Russland dort führt
die politischen Achsen in der Welt aber
sind dabei sich zu verschieben viel gibt
es zu besprechen am Rand der
Generalversammlung Treffen des Kanzlers
am Vormittag mit dem türkischen
Präsidenten der hatte vor der
Generaldebatte durchblicken lassen dass
das NATO-Mitglied Türkei jetzt auch
Mitglied in der shanghai-konferenz
werden will eine Art militär-
wir glauben dass das keine Organisation
ist die irgendwie ein ganz wichtigen
Beitrag für ein gutes Miteinander in der
Welt leistet deshalb bin ich sehr
irritiert über die Entwicklung und
Diskussionen aber am Ende ist es wichtig
dass wir uns darüber verständigen wenn
es darum geht klar zu machen dass der
russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine kein Erfolg haben darf
am Abend wird der Kanzler dann seine
Rede vor der UN-Generalversammlung
halten und es wird erwartet dass er eine
Reform der Vereinten Nationen und des
UN-Sicherheitsrates ansprechen wird
Wladimir Putin und Chinas Präsident
ciesing Ping werden wenn überhaupt die
Rede nur aus der Ferne verfolgen beide
sind nicht nach New York gereist und
machen damit einmal mehr deutlich wie
wichtig ihnen die Zukunft der Vereinten
Nationen ist
die wirtschaftlichen Folgen von
Russlands Krieg und der langgepflegten
Abhängigkeit von Russlands Gas sorgen
auch bei der Bundesregierung weiter für
Kopfzerbrechen die neueste Wendung ist
dass das Gasunternehmen Juniper
inzwischen so massive Probleme hat das
ist in den nächsten Tagen vermutlich
fast vollständig verstaatlicht wird in
einer Art Hauruck Rettungsaktion dann
aber steht die Frage im Raum ob die
gasumlage überhaupt noch so eingeführt
werden kann wie das für Ende nächster
Woche eigentlich vorgesehen ist Patricia
Wiedemeier berichtet
es war ein ständiges Hin und Her heute
laufend neue Meldungen und Dementis aus
dem Wirtschaftsministerium jedoch nichts
Konkretes zur gasumlage bestätigt wurde
nur dass das Ministerium
finanzverfassungsrechtliche Zweifel hat
dies müsse jetzt das Finanzministerium
prüfen wir haben als Deutscher Bundestag
der Bundesregierung mit dem
energiesicherheitsgesetz verschiedene
Optionen zur Verfügung gestellt und die
Bundesregierung hat sich dazu
entschlossen den Weg der Umlage zu gehen
sollte sich die Rechtsnatur der
Unternehmen ändern die von dieser Umlage
profitieren dann ist es natürlich so
dass man auch die Rechtsnatur der Umlage
noch einmal bewerten muss im Klartext
heißt das dass wohl die finanzielle Not
des gasimporteurs uniper so groß ist
dass eine Verstaatlichung anscheinend
kurz bevorsteht ob in einem solchen Fall
die gasumlage die ja ebenfalls die
gasimporteure unterstützen würde noch
rechtlich zulässig ist noch nötig ist
fraglich die SPD jedenfalls will selber
die gasumlage rechtlich prüfen
wir haben eine eigene Expertise und
werden die auch mit Expertinnen und
Experten auch noch mal in der Anhörung
beleuchten und dann werden wir auch zu
entsprechenden schlussfolgungen
innerhalb der Koalition kommt einer
Verstaatlichung von uniper würde die SPD
aber zustimmen
wenn jetzt andere auch zu dieser
Überzeugung kommen sollten dass das der
richtige Weg ist werden wir das
unterstützen sollte die gasumlage nicht
kommen dann fordert der dritte
Koalitionspartner die FDP Alternativen
eine gasumlage die so gemacht ist dass
sie die Preise senkt und dass sie
vernünftig funktioniert ist gut wenn das
nicht der Fall ist da muss man aber ein
anderes Instrument finden was nicht
ausreichen würde ist nichts zu tun das
wird nicht gehen sondern wir brauchen
hier auch nationales Handeln Liebe noch
die Union die von schlampiger Planung
spricht und erneut fordert die Gasanlage
abzuschaffen
wenn sich bestätigt dass diese Zweifel
offensichtlich im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium vorhanden
sind dann gibt es diese Woche die
Gelegenheit die gasumlage sofort zu
stoppen wir haben den Antrag dazu im
Deutschen Bundestag und werden die
Entscheidung dazu auch in dieser Woche
im Deutschen Bundestag
herbeiführen viele offene Fragen viel
Verwirrung heute in Berlin aber so wie
es aussieht könnte das Aus für die eh
nicht beliebte und umstrittene gasumlage
bald kommen
ja wir sprechen darüber noch mit unseren
Wirtschaftsfachmann Frank Bethmann Frank
dabei der ganzen Sache geht es ja nicht
nur um Juniper ja richtig mit Gazprom
Germania steht auch der zweitgrößte
gasimporteur bereits unter
Treuhandverwaltung und auch beim
drittgrößten Gashändler VNG laufen die
Verhandlungen über einen Einstieg des
Bundes mit anderen Worten die drei
größten gasimporteure Deutschland stehen
davor alle mehr oder weniger
verstaatlicht zu werden und wenn man das
in die Überlegung mit einbezieht stellt
sich manchmal die Frage ob die gasumlage
überhaupt noch Sinn ergibt wenn der Bund
bei den wichtigsten gashändlern
Eigentümer ist kann er die Konzerne ja
auch direkt stützen und absichern wobei
die gasumlage stand heute Abend ja nicht
vom Tisch ist
aber da kommen ja jetzt dann auch noch
die Stadtwerke in das Spiel von denen
gab es heute nämlich schon mal sozusagen
vorsorglich scharfe Kritik an einem
möglichen Kippen der gasumlage oh ja
beim stadtwerke-kongress in Leipzig
zeigte man sich äußerst irritiert über
die Diskussionen rein in die Kartoffeln
oder raus aus den Kartoffeln sagt
beispielsweise der Chef der Stadtwerke
Leipzig Carsten Rogall das müsste doch
irgendwann auch mal konsequent
durchgezogen werden die Stadtwerke sind
natürlich die die mit den privaten
Haushalten direkt in Kontakt stehen und
ihre Kunden längst tausendfach über die
gasumlage informiert haben jetzt Ruhe
die Rücknahme dieser Ankündigung was für
große Verunsicherung Sorge ganz
abgesehen davon dass auch die Stadtwerke
und mit ihnen die Eigentümer meist sind
das ja die Kommunen große Befürchtungen
haben ebenfalls in wirtschaftliche
Schieflage zu geraten dann nämlich wenn
immer mehr ihre Gasrechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen können der Vorstandssprecher
des Energieversorgers EWR in Worms
Stefan Wilhelm rechnet vor wenn 15
Prozent unserer Kunden ihre Rechnung
nicht mehr bezahlen können sind wir nach
drei Monaten insolvent erforderte heute
einen Rettungsschirm für Stadtwerke
Frank vielen Dank gerne und jetzt macht
erstmal Heinz Wolf weiter da gibt es
neues in Sachen Corona Impfstoffe nach
der Zulassung von corona-impfstoffen die
an die omegonvariante angepasst sind
spricht sich die Ständige Impfkommission
für deren bevorzugten Einsatz bei
Auffrischimpfungen aus in dem
Beschlussentwurf empfiehlt die STIKO
eine weitere Auffrischimpfung also eine
vierte Impfung für bestimmte
Personengruppen wie Menschen ab 60
Jahren
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
erklärte viele ältere Menschen seien
noch nicht genug gegen Omegon Varianten
geschützt
zum Weltkindertag haben der
Kinderschutzbund und
Bundesfamilienministerin Pauls zum
Schutz von Kindern vor Gewalt aufgerufen
sie stellten im Berlin eine Kampagne vor
unter der Überschrift Gewalt ist mehr
als du denkst der Präsident des
Kinderschutzbundes Hilgers sagte das
Recht auf gewaltfreie Erziehung
erschöpfe sich nicht im Verzicht auf
körperliche Bestrafungen seelische
Verletzungen gehörten leider für viele
Kinder zum Alltag sei es im Elternhaus
aber auch in der Kita oder Schule
das deutsche seenotrettungsschiff
humanity One hat von italienischen
Behörden die Erlaubnis bekommen einen
Hafen anzulaufen an Bord sind 398
gerettete darunter 55 Kinder und 110
unbegleitete Minderjährige so die
Organisation SOS humanity einige von
ihnen befinden sich bereits seit etwa
zwei Wochen an Bord die Lage ist der
Organisation zufolge kritisch
Infektionskrankheiten breiten sich aus
Wasser und Essen mussten rationiert
werden
allein in diesem Jahr kamen bei dem
Versuch das Mittelmeer zu überqueren
nach un-eingaben mehr als 1000 Migranten
ums Leben oder werden vermisst
der Hurricane Fiona richtet in der
Karibik gerade schwere Schäden an
mindestens drei Menschen kamen bislang
ums Leben in der Dominikanischen
Republik war in der Hälfte aller
Provinzen die Alarmstufe Rot ausgerufen
worden viele Orts kam es zu
Stromausfällen und Überschwemmungen
davor hatte Fiona schon auf Puerto Rico
gewütet und mittlerweile ist der
Hurrikan auch über die zu Großbritannien
gehörenden Turks und cakers-inseln
hinweggezogen berichte über Schäden gibt
es von dort noch keine
die anlasslose
Vorratsdatenspeicherung dürfte ein
Begriff sein den viele vielleicht nicht
auf anni mit ganz viel detaillierten
Inhalt füllen können aber gehört hat man
ihn schon oft kein Wunder das Thema ist
ein juristischer Dauerbrenner der
Europäische Gerichtshof hat sich schon
mehrfach damit befasst und heute erneut
entschieden die deutschen Regelungen
sind nicht mit EU-Recht vereinbar das
sagen die Richter schon länger deshalb
ist die Verpflichtung der
Telekommunikationsunternehmen zu einer
generellen Datenspeicherung auch schon
seit fünf Jahren ausgesetzt
letztlich geht es in diesem Konflikt um
die Abwägung zwischen den Bedürfnissen
von Ermittlern bei der Verbrecherjagd
gegenüber dem Recht unbescholtener
Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf Datenschutz
das Urteil heute in Berlin aufgenommen
wurde berichtet Nicole Diekmann
wer steht mit seinem Handy wo mit wem
telefoniert er wem schickt er eine
Nachricht der gläserne Mensch komplett
durchleuchtet mit Hilfe seiner
Mobilfunkdaten das ist längst möglich
aber das ist nicht rechtens denn das
speichert von Daten darüber wer wie mit
wem kommuniziert oder das Internet
genutzt hat sowie über das wann wie
lange und wo kann sehr genaue Schlüsse
auf das Privatleben zulassen und das
Erstellen eines Profils ermöglichen
selbst wenn diese Daten nur für wenige
Wochen gespeichert werden die Debatte
ist fast so alt wie das Internet immer
wieder taucht die Forderung auf Telefon
und Internetdaten zu speichern von allen
Nutzern zum Beispiel um im Kampf gegen
Kindesmissbrauch schlagkräftiger zu sein
und immer wieder so auch heute urteilen
Gerichte die anlasslose Speicherung auf
Vorrat ist verfassungswidrig und
trotzdem tobt der Jahre alte Streit
weiter auch nach dem Urteil nun zwischen
den ampelparteien FDP und SPD
die Speicherung der Daten mit denen wir
Täter identifizieren können ist
unbedingt erforderlich hierfür sind die
IP-Adressen von entscheidender Bedeutung
die nach dem Urteil des heutigen die
heutige Entscheidung des EuGH
ausdrücklich bestätigt gespeichert
werden dürfen
IP-Adressen eine Art Telefonnummer im
Internet zu speichern das hatte faesar
schon vor dem heutigen Urteil gefordert
das Problem die FDP lehnt das ab und
fühlt sich darin heute ebenfalls
bestätigt genauso wie in ihrer Forderung
nach dem sogenannten
quickfreeze-verfahren dem schnellen
Sichern von Daten bei Verdacht auf eine
Straftat
Jahre ist das der EuGH hat es
ausdrücklich bestätigt und es ist eben
das Modell das dem Vorgaben des
Koalitionsvertrages entspricht der ja
eindeutig sagt nur wenn ein Anlass
gegeben ist kann gespeichert werden und
dazu muss ein Richter oder eine
Richterin dazu entscheiden der Graben
verläuft zwischen Faser auf der einen
und FDP sowie Grünen auf der anderen
Seite auch die fördern quick freeze und
außerdem die momentan ausgesetzte
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ganz zu kippen
unterstützung kommt von digitalexperten
sie fördern Pragmatismus statt Ideologie
die Vorratsdatenspeicherung klingt
natürlich aus Sicht von allen
Ermittlerinnen und Politikerinnen wie
eine Wundertüte alle Daten werden
erstmal gespeichert das sehr
vergleichbar wie wenn unsere aller
Fingerabdrücke erstmal in Datenbanken
gespeichert werden würden und wenn
irgendwo ein Fingerabdruck verdächtig
ist dann kann man erstmal abgleichen wer
war da dabei gibt es viel effizientere
strafverfolgungsmöglichkeiten
Strafverfolger hingegen drängen auf das
Speichern von IP-Adressen damit könne
die Aufklärungsquote bei sexuellen
Kindesmissbrauch von derzeit 75 auf 90%
gesteigert werden
immer digitaler wir haben Hinweise auch
eine Straftat wir wissen wann sie war
wir haben eine IP-Adresse und wir müssen
feststellen wer war das die Debatte um
die Vorratsdatenspeicherung sieht rot zu
unendlichen Geschichte zu werden danach
sieht es zumindest heute aus mal wieder
und zu dem Thema gibt es nachher im
heute journal Update noch ein Interview
mit BKA-Chef Holger Nitsch und jetzt
nochmal Heinz mit anderen Meldungen die
Erzeugerpreise also die Preise ab
Fabriktor bevor die Produkte
weiterverarbeitet werden oder in den
Handel kommen sind im August um
durchschnittlich
45,8 Prozent gestiegen vor allem wegen
teurere Energie laut Statistischem
Bundesamt ist es der höchste Anstieg
gegenüber einem Vorjahresmonat seit
Beginn der Erhebung 1949 und im Juli lag
der Anstieg noch bei rund 37%
die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft
hatte heute ihr erstes Training vor den
beiden nations League spielen gegen
Ungarn und England Offensivspieler muss
Jana beendete es nach einem Zweikampf
mit seinem Münchner Teamkollegen Thomas
Müller vorzeitig die Entschuldigung
folgte direkt nach dem faul nach einem
Zweikampf mit Müller zieht sich musiala
eine Risswunde am rechten Schienbein zu
und muss schließlich das Training
abbrechen ein Ausfall gegen Ungarn
selber nicht zu befürchten Teil der DFB
mit die bayern-fraktion hat es eh schon
nicht leicht in diesen Tagen die Krise
im Club holt Kimmich und Co auch im
Nationalteam ein man ärgert sich schon
brutal auch heute schon im
Trainingsspiel da war das auch so ein
bisschen sinnbildlich Daten auch die ein
oder andere Chance am Ende verlierst du
dann wieder weil er die Dinger vorne
nicht machst man hat es schon noch so
ein bisschen im Hinterkopf natürlich die
sieben Bayern-Profis beim DFB müssen die
sieglosserie im Verein möglichst schnell
aus den Kleidern schütteln doch
Rückschläge sind derzeit ein ständiger
Begleiter so tauchte Manuel Neuer nur in
Badeschlappen auf konnte wegen
Beschwerden am Zeh nicht mittrainieren
das was von uns gleich folgt die
Reportage Reihe 37 Grad heute unter dem
Titel du sollst hören eine junge
Schauspielerin die von Geburt an fast
vollständig gehörlos ist aber von klein
auf so trainiert wurde das hören die ihr
das gar nicht anmerken sie selbst wurde
damit aber nicht glücklich ein
faszinierendes Porträt sehr
empfehlenswert und um 0.30 gibt es dann
unser heute schon mal Update mit Nazan
gökte mir und uns morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter heute
Abend ja das Satellitenbild von heute
Nachmittag zeigt uns Deutschland unter
Wolken teilweise kamen da nur bis drei
Stunden Sonne zusammen aber
Schleswig-Holstein und Dänemark da
schien die Sonne den ganzen Tag rund 10
Stunden lang ja wie kam das zustande nun
die feuchte kühle Luft aus dem
Nordwesten die muss um hier anzukommen
erstmal über das norwegische Gebirge
drüber und wenn sie dahinter absinkt
dann trocknet sie auch ab und hat nicht
mehr genug feuchte um Wolken zu bilden
und dieser sogenannte Skandinavien föhnt
bricht aber in der nächsten Zeit in sich
zusammen denn dieses Hoch Stefan breitet
sich jetzt zu uns aus bringt uns mehr
Sonne am Tag dafür aber auch mehr Nebel
in der Nacht und kältere Nächte und das
ist auch heute Nacht schon der Fall 11
bis 4 Grad gibt es meist nur noch im
Südosten und in der Lüneburger Heide
sind es nur drei bis 0 Grad morgen früh
und das bedeutet Bodenfrost vielleicht
Eiskratzen und vor allem gibt es das
dort wo es heute Nacht aufklärt denn die
Schauer fallen jetzt so langsam in sich
zusammen etwas Regen bzw Schnee gibt es
noch in den östlichen Alpen der Wind
schläft auch ein deswegen kann sich der
Nebel ausbreiten und der muss sich dann
morgen Vormittag erst einmal auflösen
dann gibt es aber viel Sonne vor allem
im Norden und im Südwesten einige
Quellwolken sind am Tag unterwegs die
vor allem über den Mittelgebirgen
Dichter sein können und von der Lausitz
und dem Erzgebirge bis zum Bayerischen
Wald Schauer dabei haben können das
ganze bei Temperaturen zwischen 13 und
19 Grad bis Freitag wird es dann etwas
milder es gibt viel Sonne einige Wolken
sind mit von der Partie erst am Samstag
gibt es von Westen her dann wieder etwas
Regen tschüss